[Music]
jakie accused you of murder in a public
forum no one takes it serious that's
what kids do they just try to sound cool
that's all it is honest the book grew
out of my experiences as a prosecutor
mark preserved the essence of the novel
which is this isn't a crime story about
a family this is a family story that
happens to be about a crime you really
think I don't think it's a mistake we're
gonna figure it out don't worry for me
the fun of being a screenwriter is
finding source material and saying
what's the best cinematic version of
this story what was so exciting was that
you could open the story up to explore
all of these possibilities that series
TV allows you to do the first time art
gave me all the episodes I was like
alright I'll just read one tonight and
you know think it's B and you're like I
gotta read the next one now we have
Morton Tobin directing all eight
episodes so really has a uniformity of
directorial vision I love working with
mark on this it was great to work very
closely together he knew exactly what he
liked what he wanted to do
to see Morton work and realize how high
the standards are explains how he's able
to achieve what he achieved on screen
small team they're not against murder
you get to choose you can be a good man
or you can be a good father one of the
challenges in adapting it is that I
don't want to be limited to just Andy's
perspective I want it to be
Lori's perspective Jacobs perspective
then doing out of patience you're not
seeing it through the eyes of the cops
or victims you actually seeing it
through this family to have these
incredibly exciting actors who differ
from the characters in the book with
respect to their age or their appearance
is wonderful he didn't do this I know he
didn't one can sustain that level of
deception of course he could bills book
in the show even more so really tries to
explore how dark
can you believe Jacob is and still hold
on to this glimmer of hope that it's
impossible he could have done this I
didn't do it I swear
do you know what's at stake do you
realize what they want to do to you were
you
scaring him good he should be scared I'm
scared
you
you